fuegos artificiales para celebrar un
resultado que nunca estuvo en duda estas
imágenes de la televisión siria muestran
a miles de partidarios del presidente
reunidos en la capital damasco bashar
al-asad está preparado para un cuarto
mandato hasta ahora su familia ha estado
por casi seis décadas en el poder
en un mensaje online agradeció a
aquellos que emitieron un voto y dijo
que la campaña para reconstruir la
esperanza en el país comenzaría de forma
inmediata robert ir a votación fue la
segunda desde el inicio del conflicto
hace diez años que ha matado a más de
388.000 personas y desplazado a millones
la vez pasada en 2014 al asad se alzó
con el 88 por ciento del voto esta vez
incluso mejoró superando a dos
candidatos prácticamente desconocidos
que entre ambos recibieron un poco menos
del 5% del total de los votos
ojalá
bashar y al cafés al asad recibió 13
millones 540 mil 860 votos que
representan el 90 y 5.1 por ciento del
total de los votos válidos
la elección ha sido condenada como ni
libre ni justa por numerosos países
occidentales incluidos eeuu para asia y
alemania la fragmentada oposición siria
la ha descrito como una farsa el
balotaje tuvo lugar con los niveles de
violencia más bajos desde 2011 al asad
control ahora algo más de dos tercios
del país analistas afirman que su
principal reto será manejar una economía
que permanece en caída libre con una
inflación disparada y más del 80 por
ciento de la población viviendo en la
pobreza